prophet sent
in the history of prophethood. He's the
last.
He's the last prophet. He's the last
messenger.
But interestingly enough,
as he is the imam of the prophets,
he is the imam of all Muslims
of
humanity of humankind and gen.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam's
prophethhood will have a profound effect
on every human being before him.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions this
in
he says
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says to the
prophet Sam
hopefully
likely
Allah will raise you to a distinct
level of high praise.
A level and stature of praise
where
the people will all praise the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam for his favor upon
them.
Now this
verse was explained by the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam himself
in which
he mentions that it is
the major intercession on the day of
judgment.
And in the narration
of
Abdah
in Bkari Muslim the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam says
I have been given five unique things
that no other prophet before me has been
given. And one of those unique things,
I have been granted the position of
major intercession.
major intercession meaning that Allah
will choose him as a representative
to
intercede on behalf of all of mankind
and gen. The prophet sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam says also in the
narration of he says
I have been sent
to both the humankind and the jin kind
and the story of his intercession his
major intercession meaning he will
intercede on behalf of everyone
has been told to us in Bkari in Sah
Muslim by a number of the companions to
the point that this is an issue that is
well known amongst the Muslim. It is
considered to be something that is
it is something that is known across the
board and acknowledged by
all of the Muslim
and so many companions have mentioned
this. So many companions have narrated
it that it is beyond
the you know this this point or this
fact is beyond debate. It is beyond
debate and for this reason the scholars
of a sunnah in listing the
characteristics of the people of the
sunnah in their books on belief and
in their books on creed and ethos. They
mention and they list that one of the
traits of the people of the sunnah is
that they affirm the major intercession
of the prophet sallall.aii wasallam. So
what are the details behind this
intercession? I believe everyone here
has heard of this intercession before.
Everyone here is aware of it. They're
aware that our prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam will be given this major
intercession. But what does that mean?
What are the details behind it?
We have an narration here
on the authority of
[Silence]
Abu Huru narrates that the messenger of
Allah sallall.aii alaihi wasallam was
invited by someone invited by one of the
companions in Medina to eat to have
lunch or dinner and we were with him. So
he took a band of his closest companions
with him to honor this invitation.
And when he arrived and the
food was served, he was
specifically given the shoulder cut from
the animal because this was known to be
his favorite you know cut of meat.
And so he took a piece, he ate, and then
he said,
"I am the most honorable
of people on the day of judgment."
Do you want to know why?
He says,
[Silence]
He says, "Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will
bring forth and resurrect all of the
people." the first and the last of them,
all of humanity and gen. Of course,
wherever you see the human beings
mentioned in resurrection or entering
paradise or entering the hellfire, the
jin are
included in that generality. He said,
"So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will
resurrect everyone. Us, we're all going
to be there. He will resurrect us all
and he will bring them all forth on one
level plane of land. All of them
together. It's almost impossible to
fathom the sheer numbers, the billions
upon billions of human beings that will
be there. He says,
"And so they will see very well. They
will hear
and they will all be standing there
awaiting Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to
come and judge them
and the sun will be brought very close
in other narrations a mile from people
they will start to sweat and they will
be in sheer panic and in a state of
horror.
He says,
"So the people will then say to one
another," meaning they're waiting,
they're waiting, they're waiting,
nothing's happening. They're waiting for
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to come and
judge them.
So the people will say to one another,
people will finally after waiting say to
each other, "Do you not see the terror,
the difficulty that we are currently
enduring?
We should look for someone who can
intercede on our behalf for the judgment
to commence and this misery to end. You
know the anticipation, the the terror,
the discomfort, the claustrophobia.
And so they will start to discuss who
this person could be that could
intercede on their behalf.
Adam,
[Silence]
so they will decide.
that the best person that comes to mind
is Adam.
Why? Because when you choose someone to
represent you and to appeal to someone
that you are at his mercy,
you choose the best person, the best of
you to represent you. So they will go to
Adamisam
and they will say to him, "Yeah, Adam,
you are the forefather and first of all
of humanity. Allah created you with his
hand and he placed in you his special
soul that he created for you and he
commanded the angels to make sujud and
he made your home paradise. Do you not
see the difficulty and the terror and
anticipation that we are in? Will you
not please intercede on our behalf?
[Silence]
He will then say his response to them is
today
Allah has become angry with an anger he
has never had before. He has never been
angry this before. Nor will he ever
become angry this again. And Allah
commanded me and I disobeyed his
command.
I am worried about my own self right
now. I don't know what's going to happen
to me myself. Myself. And this is really
the mantra of the people on the day of
judgment. Nepsi Nepsi Nevsi. Go to
someone else. Find someone else. Go to
Noah.
for
[Silence]
Nefi. NFC.
And so they will then go to
a upon taking instruction from Adam
and they will say to oh no, you are the
first messenger to the people of the
earth and Allah has referred to you as a
thankful
servant.
Do you not see what we are under? The
pressure that we are under? Do you not
see the difficulty that we are in and
the anticipation
that we are in? And so
will respond,
"My Lord today has become angry with an
anger he has never become angry with
before,
nor will he ever have an anger this
again." And I had a guaranteed dua one
that was mine. No matter what it was, I
could make it for my people. And I
already made it upon my people in the
dunya. I am worried about myself,
myself, myself, myself.
Go to Ibraim.
Go to someone else. Now when we look at
this narration we see that
he has a couple of things that are
mentioned in this narration. Number one
is the first messenger to the people of
the earth. Adam was the first prophet. N
was the first messenger.
And it is incorrect even though it is
widespread amongst many historians
that they list
as being before
No. This is an opinion held by some of
the scholars and it is mainly taken from
the people of the book and any other
prophets that are listed before No.
There's no evidence for that from the
Quran or authentic Sunnah of the prophet
Sam.
What's clear in the Quran is that Allah
says,
"We have sent revelation to you as we
have to before you and all the
subsequent prophets." So Allah lists
prophethood as subsequent
afteram.
Another issue here that is brought up is
that no
has a dwa he has a dua that Allah gave
him. This is Allah's gift to every
messenger
and every messenger has already
exhausted this da except for our prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. Noam his dwah was
documented in surah no also misam as
we'll come to hear his da'wah was
documented in surah ununus etc. So each
prophet has a guaranteed dua for his
people and all messengers have exhausted
and used up that dua in either making
dua against their enemies or making dua
for their followers except for the
prophet Muhammad sallallah.aii wasallam.
He was given the opportunity to make
this dua many times. Many times however
he kept it. He saved it for the day of
judgment specifically.
We will continue this narration
[Arabic recitation]